SESSION BACK AND FORTH.
WE WILL GO THERE WHEN IT BREAKS
UP.
THE PRESIDENT IS EXPECTED TO
SPEAK TO REPORTERS OF THAT
MICROPHONE.
IT WAS ANOTHER DAY OF SOME
INTENSE QUESTIONING FOR THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
INSPECTOR GENERAL TODAY.
AT ISSUE, WHAT PART POLITICS AND
PREJUDICE PLAYED IN THE FBI'S
INVESTIGATION OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL SCANDAL
AND BY EXTENSION THE ONGOING
PROBE INTO RUSSIA ELECTION
INTERFERENCE.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS WATCHING.
>> THEY PREJUDGED THE OUTCOME OF
THE HILLARY CLINTON EMAIL
INVESTIGATION BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION ENDED.
THESE EXACT SAME FBI AGENTS AND
ATTORNEYS PREJUDGED THE OUTCOME
OF THE RUSSIA INVESTIGATION
BEFORE IT EVEN BEGAN.
>> DURING A SECOND DAY OF
TESTIMONY, LAWMAKERS PRESSED
MICHAEL HOROWITZ OVER WHAT
REPUBLICANS DESCRIBED AS
POLITICAL BIAS AT THE FBI
IMPACTING THE PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN.
THEY POINT TO AN AUGUST 2016
TEXT BETWEEN PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE SAYING THAT THEY WOULD
STOP TRUMP FROM BEING ELECTED.
>> I WONDER WHO THE "WE" IS AND
WE WILL STOP IT.
>> A BROADER GROUP BEYOND THAT?
WE HAVE FOUND THREE ADDITIONAL
FBI AGENTS.
>> SOME TRANSITION TO THE RUSSIA
SPECIAL CAUSAL INVESTIGATION.
>> DO THEY STILL WORK FOR
MUELLER?
>> MY UNDERSTANDING IS NO.
>> AGENT STRZOK PIVOTED FROM THE
CLINTON EMAILS TO COLLUSION.
>> DO YOU BELIEVE THE POLITICAL
BIAS SHOWN IN THIS TEXT HAD THE
EFFECT OF THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION?
>> IT'S UNDER REVIEW.
>> A FORENSIC REVIEW OF THE
PHONES UNCOVERED THE EXPLOSIVE
TEXTED ME.
CONGRESS WASN'T IMMEDIATELY
NOTIFIED.
AT >> WE SENT IT TO THE OFFICE
OF THE DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL.
>> MR. ROSENSTEIN.
>> HIS OFFICE.
>> MR. ROSENSTEIN DECIDED WE
COULDN'T GET IT UNTIL YOUR
REPORT CAME OUT.
HE SAT ON IT FOR A MONTH.
>> A LAWMAKER QUESTIONED WHY THE
REPORT WAS TALENT ON ALLEGATIONS
THAT THE CLINTON SERVER WAS
HACKED.
THE PRESIDENT WEIGHED IN.
>> WHEN YOU READ THE IG REPORT
ABOUT HOW SHE GOT AWAY WITH WHAT
SHE GOT AWAY WITH, IT'S A
DISGRACE.
>> AFTER REVIEWS AND
INVESTIGATION, DEMOCRATS BLAME
JAMES COMEY AND ACCUSED
REPUBLICANS OF REFUSING TO
KNOWLEDGE THAT A CLINTON
PROSECUTION WAS NEVER JUSTIFIED.
>> THE HOWLING ABOUT "LOCK HER
UP" WAS BOGUS.
IT WAS BASELESS.
IT WAS UNSUBSTANTIATED.
>> JAMES COMEY DECIDED TO PLAY
JUDGE, JURY, AND EXECUTIONER.
ON OCTOBER 28 COME HE EXECUTED
THE HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
>> THE HEARING CONCLUDED AFTER
SIX AND A HALF HOURS OF
TESTIMONY.
INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ
CONFIRMED HE IS FOLLOWING UP ON
ALLEGATIONS THAT FBI INTERVIEW
SUMMARIES WERE ALTERED.
>> Bret: THERE WAS SOME LATE
NEWS THIS AFTERNOON ON FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK.
>> IN A STATEMENT, STRZOK'S
ATTORNEY CONFIRMED HIS CLIENT
HAS BEEN FULLY COOPERATING WITH
AN INTERNAL FBI REVIEW WHICH
INCLUDED RECENTLY BEING ESCORTED
FROM THE FBI BUILDING.
THE STATEMENT SAID AT LEAST FOR